[Applaudissements]
d'abord parce que kelly c'est la mort il
adore mais en plus c'est la meuf qui
marche le moins doucement possible c'est
à dire que quand elles marchent pas
l'impression de vous coller à fait pas
si noir alors et hier c'est votre
anniversaire
oui l'été quoi d'hier soir rien vous
deviez pas le restaurant baoshi arrive
vous justement des personnes nous
j'aimerais bien qu'on revienne là-dessus
vous deviez aller au resto avec vous et
avec vous avec berry et son mari et
qu'elle y est alors un restaurant
japonais ne s'est pas blessé quand les
caméras sont éteintes tout le monde sait
qu'à ce maladroit pena il m'a planté
oui oui vous aussi bas que ceux qui
payent dur mais il vous est attendu au
restaurant japonais restant l'été moi
j'étais au travail sont des maquis quoi
et donc vous allez rien fait pour votre
animal non merci
qu'est ce que vous voulez dire non jeune
fils l'ont pris le maquis allez on y va
quand même beaucoup de mecs sur la
seconde guerre mondiale ou comment ça se
passe merci bravo très drôle non
vraiment ça va vous sinon un mozart est
radié de votre anniversaire d'ailleurs
en automne en automne
entre le matin sa tombe et 22 novembre
et alors là tu vois c'est vraiment été
c'est de tomber dessus
c'est bon on est tous les deux balances
vous du 23 septembre du 1er octobre
ah ouais on est jeune on s'entend si
bien mais voilà non mais c'est vrai et
mon père et du 3 octobre et l'année mais
pas tout à fait la même
bon c'est pas loin
un siècle près à lennik et surtout de
suite bonjour je m'appelle najma je suis
très embêté parce que je ne sais pas
quoi regarder à la télé ce soir
vous qui êtes tous des spécialistes hors
pair dans les médias pouvez vous m'aider
car je me sens seul est dépourvu il y
aura camille combal en invités entre
exactement
oui en tout cas comme cette question
leur naturel pas joué du tout eh bien
chers najma je sais pas quoi vous dire
moi je sais ce que j'aurais envie de
regarder mais comme je peux pas avoir
l'impression d'être partisan je me suis
dit que pour vous aider le mieux était
de demander l'avis d'un spécialiste qui
a toujours un avis très tranché et
honnête sur les programmes quelqu'un
qu'on ne pourra pas soupçonner d'être
complaisant avec moi matthieu delormeau
[Applaudissements]
j en étais ce qui n'a pas bien joué à
renier dedans c'est ce volet parker
à
c'est un nom j'avais pas vu sur ces huit
ce soit il ya ici c'est le moine au ca
al air vraiment génial merci match est
bien attaché
il est franc comme non mais ce que je
vois c'est isabelle à côté qui sert il
il est franc mais pendant la pub allez
comme un i did a changé en tout cas ça
fait plaisir qu'il échet la pub pour mon
émission ce soir alors qu'on te
remercier mathieu un nouvel épisode de
thé aventure avec à gâteau proulx alors
dans le premier épisode
mathieu agathe avait prouvé qu'ils
étaient vraiment les meilleurs amis du
monde aujourd'hui et bah c'est toujours
aussi chaleureux d'agathe vient
effleurer celle de mathieu sous la table
[Musique]
jolie surprise année dernière je pense
que personne
[Applaudissements]
mais m
m
l'engrenage
ce système carrière
j'ai parlé
[Applaudissements]
elle m'a longtemps au sein pas parfois
un peu tendu mais heureusement
heureusement avec l'état pour ramener de
la paix de l'harmonie entre nous cyril
hanouna par exemple pour que tout le
monde s'entende bien il avait eu une
nouvelle idée merveilleuse faire voter
les chroniqueurs pour savoir qui
méritait une augmentation à oui ça se
fait beaucoup dans les séminaires de
quoi ils ont dit donc avant le vote
chacun devait expliquer pourquoi c'est
lui qui devait être augmenté moi par
exemple je vais jouer la carte de la
menace et ça n'a pas plu à tout le monde
car il ya des gens qui ont une morale
autour de cette table que d'une seule
chose qui marche si si c'est le chantage
j'ai vraiment des dossiers faut plus de
monde que je n'ai jamais montré ni même
sur moi évidemment sur l'abandon car
récemment cheveux tous vous faire tomber
donc vaudra mieux même augmenté mais
vite
[Rires]
pourquoi cette méthode
[Musique]
résumons
tous les mois
[Applaudissements]
alors ils ont fait ça brille c'est pour
ça qu'il était très énervé après la
séquence
ah oui bon au final c'est benjamin
castaldi qui est gagné et ça a fait
plaisir à tout le monde
enfin enfin presque fallait quand même
que je vous montre la tête de jean
michel et maxime au moment des résultats
ça se passe de commentaire c'est magique
[Applaudissements]
denis pays-bas formidable
le reste est bénin au premier degré
c'est ouf merci à mes la tête de janvier
faudra maîtriser
allez on passe au top j'ai dans sa
compilation des petits moments étranges
de tpm b
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
trop
[Musique]
maxime gainey moi je peux pas te verrai
[Rires]
[Musique]
guy lux va faire intervilles elle est
toujours une bannière on lui a pas dit
qu'on avait déménagé
[Musique]
c'est le boulot des parts quelle femme
non c'était l'enjeu c'est s était pas
c'était ma femme était ma femme en fait
expliqué je ne peux pas vous le dire une
pénétration de bourg-madame kelly
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un instant on parlera également mes
chéris avec magloire
il sera avec vous il va venir me voir
[Musique]
c'est une personne qui est venu
pour gilles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
g
il
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les premiers degrés veut maintenant
passer un gros dossier à houla voilà
très gros dossier un secret de
fabrication de tp mpc quand je montre ce
qui se cache derrière les images
diffusées à l'antenne
rassure moi si un petit peu alors je
préviens c'est un des plus gros que j'ai
eu depuis que j'ai cette rubrique un
plan machiavélique en 52 et apnée dans
le cerveau d'un génie du mal et cela
peut bien être mais ça fait des semaines
que je voulais passer vous allez voir ce
qu'il ya quelqu'un qui a pas la même
coupe de cheveux
c'est le jour où cyril hanouna a décidé
de donner des vannes à maxime gainey
pour le transformer en sniper de
l'émission embryons que vous auriez
voulu oublier mais non je vous ai fait
un bâtard
[Musique]
on avait à mon avi chesla isabelle
joschke minimum des cibles
- m
m
je dirais même plus c'est cette vous
avec votre mari douze coups de minuit à
minuit
ces mini jeux surtout
[Musique]
chassang
saturne leurs deux recrues - tu le plus
gros épaulard que la terre n'ait jamais
créé ok ça permettra boîte à camembert
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous en avez une affaire non de
nombreuses d'accord si ce qu'est ce
qu'il ya ohlala les snipers
[Applaudissements]
ça aurait pu s'arrêter là
non en bon ça aurait dû s'arrêter là
mais non je rappelle que c'est cyril
hanouna
je veux qu'il ne supporte pas le bruit
cheikh donc à la pause publicitaire
suivant la suite c'est là qu'on s'est
aperçu que si ma kiné padilha vannes au
moment voulu c'est juste parce que
depuis le début il capterait absolument
rien à ce qu'on lui disait à rigoler aux
vins du patron mais savait pas pourquoi
[Musique]
vraiment
je prends bien organisée une musique
parce qu'ils soient
[Musique]
jean-michel étiez vous promettiez sur
prague de baxi s'est bien marré mais
c'est brent easy on sait se met sur ta
tête tu t'arrêtes en croissance
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment arriver à l'antenne
je vais lui était midi ça ça ça fait du
bien ah c'est bon ça fait du bien bon il
y en a un peu plus doux mais quand même
bien entendu et on commence par benjamin
castaldi qui compte obtenir sa légende
de la semaine dernière qu'est ce qu'il a
fait il a pété
c'est ce que personne s'est trompé ça on
peut les interroger sur les questions
médias là qui va payer maison sur ta
page ambitionnons il déçoit jamais je
sais ce qu'il a fait il a lâché une
caisse et en faisant ça il a failli
envoyer aux urgences et des gens qui
étaient aussi d'ailleurs lui non bon
anniversaire benjamin
[Musique]
alors sonel j'ai eu un choc 100
personnes c'est une personne nommément
jamin kalach heynckes à l'évacuation de
l'eau vers nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je me suis fait larguer parce que je
n'avais pas si pas pris assez poitrine
isabelle c'est bon quand je largue lkp
[Musique]
c'est chez moi
c'est pour nous deux s'ils sont jalouses
et en paix pour eux
agathe alors agathe vous avez 25 ans 25
au 26 26 temps passe
c'est
devinette
c'est le journal japonais
[Musique]
comment une démission qui n'a jamais vu
qu'elle n'a jamais fait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
c'était trop bien pour moi
on va taper plus haut israël va gigoter
en trois secondes il réjoui c'est pas
faire
[Applaudissements]